if anybody's headphones are too loud you
can let me know and i'll drop the volume
look at you
i like that we just go into this
assuming you megan on the ones and twos
i'm very i'm very impressed you got a
whole mix board there jesus what is that
when when somebody says that somebody's
on the ones and twos i've never heard
that before what oh really megan on the
ones and twos you've heard that right
yeah isn't it like turntables or
something yeah
turn table one turntable two so this is
the show uh
it's
oh we started yeah oh okay well we have
no structure to it so we're i think
we'll just we'll just talk i think a
structure will eventually emerge uh but
you're sort of like the show yeah right
you're gonna have to sit through quite a
few episodes before it gets good
just like the show just like the show
yeah i was telling rob earlier just on a
show related thing that i had some queso
cheese on on sunday
today is wednesday mm-hmm how'd that do
you my stomach still hurts yeah uh and
so very unlike my character i just can't
ever i should never go anywhere near
cheap but okay this is a conversation
that we have had this feels like so keep
doing it keep doing it yes we've had
this conversation for 14 years 14 years
no early on i didn't know it was the
cheese that was messing me up we knew it
was something well but you you also but
you had an aversion to creamy things you
knew creamy things were related
anytime anything creamy came across your
plate you were like that this could be a
problem i had a hunch but it was a lazy
hunch like an alcoholic's like i should
probably stop drinking you know what i
mean like but doesn't do anything so i
was just like eating cheese willy-nilly
and then i stopped and started feeling
better and then every now and then i
just i'm like well i could probably do
it now it's probably fine now my stomach
is learned yeah
as as you get older your stomach
generally gets stronger right i'll yeah
i'll tame my stomach with cheese and
cream right yeah
just like everything else we had that
conversation and then try to figure out
a way to put it into the show which is
what we did by making your character
obsessed with cheese
also weirdly just it just just seems
like some things are just funny the word
yeah cheese is fun cheese is funny
eggs eggs are funny eggs are funny i
don't know why you know what else is
funny guys racism
by the way i was thinking this because
i guess part of the structure is we'll
watch an episode and talk about it so we
just watched the first episode and now
we're talking about it we never had any
intention of that being our first
episode right like that was that the
second episode that was written no no no
the second was charlie wants an abortion
was it yes i thought that was the third
one that was written no no cancer
abortion yes no
no it was originally called the gang
gets hit
that was originally the title for the
gang
it feels less appropriate
um but that was fx was like no we should
lead off well they thought that the gang
gets racist would be more accessible
which is
unbelievable now anybody that
understands what we're trying to do with
the show recognizes what we're trying to
do with that particular episode and i
would venture to say that in a lot of
ways we failed it was
but that's looking back on the lens of
today as being 44 and being in 2021 and
that was
i don't know how old what year was that
1983 the camera seemed to suggest it was
the camera suggested it was 1983 however
it was in fact 2000 2005 that aired yeah
yeah yeah i think our hearts were in the
right places but maybe um maybe there's
a couple of things in there we'd
probably adjust well i think you know i
think at that time i think that we
weren't as conscious of the fact we knew
we were making a show about bad people
doing bad things and satirizing bad
people doing bad things and we certainly
as people didn't endorse their behavior
but at the same time i don't think we
were quite as good at making it clear
that the people who were creating the
show were not also horrible people i
mean
or maybe i'm wrong i don't i mean i
can't see it the way obviously the
audience sees it well so much of the
show and so much of the characters is
about ignorance like so much of the
comedy is coming from their their
ignorance which is a byproduct of their
arrogance right and so it's kind of
funny to see the collision of those two
things these super arrogant people who
are like oh i have these strong beliefs
about why i'm right
mixed with this intense ignorance and
then you put that against the lens of
race it's extraordinarily uncomfortable
but that was the show we were making
we're like well let's look at the things
that we are all getting wrong
but then it's tough it's a moving target
things have changed so much to be like
well even your way that you're trying to
say this is wrong it's wrong and maybe
that's fair i don't know if that's fair
i don't know how i feel about it i don't
know please don't make me figure it all
out no no no not smart enough i'm not
smart enough
i'm not
can we all acknowledge that you know
like i think it's good to acknowledge
that can i just say that and then i'll
never be in trouble like guys i'm not
smart enough i'm too dumb to know what
i've done too no
the answers of now and the answers of 15
years in the future yeah we can
definitely admit that we were trying our
best
right yeah but but we did want to make a
show
no no listen yeah all joking we were
definitely trying our best because we we
did we we were relentless welcome to our
sunny podcast apology tour yeah yeah
we're like okay this one uh look how do
we how do we approach this
no there's a lot of great stuff that i
absolutely stand by in that episode same
i'd say glenn's drunk acting that was
really scary for me i remember being
there on the day scary what do you mean
well cause i was like oh [ __ ] this guy's
good and i'm like just trying to keep up
with him i remember everybody talking
about they were like that was really
good drunk acting or whatever and i was
like oh very proud of myself or whatever
but that was like before charlie had had
a chance to do any like real drunk
acting and certainly caitlyn had and i
mean now it's like you guys as drunk
acting blows mine out of the water or
danny on the plane when he's trying to
chug down those beers the box up yeah
drunk acting is not that hard it is for
me i find it quite well acting in
general for you is
a challenge a challenge but that's
all the more impressive yeah we're
busting your balls you're very good well
you can see me just trying to keep up
well in that scene actually i would
argue great and that's i i actually it's
one of my favorite scenes of yours in
the early seasons i almost like to say
for the record like i'm weirdly
uncomfortable with my acting in the
first two or three seasons of the show
like especially the first season like i
just don't think i'd found it yet like i
was
like i think it was still like so
concerned with everything feeling real
that like wasn't willing yet to embrace
the absurdity of what it could be at
times a perfect example of that actually
is something that i wanted to cut from
the episode that is has become like one
of the most iconic moments from the
first season where my character is
concerned at least in terms of comments
i get but
is that the boys are out tonight spin
move that i do when i grab that dollar
bill
i think i did that one take where i did
that all the other i didn't do that in
any other take i did that in one take
just to make you guys laugh just to do
something outrageous just to kind of you
know mix things up and then you guys
wanted to put in the show and i was like
no no no that wasn't meant to be in the
show that was meant to make you guys
laugh that's insane
that's so broad
it's so broad we can't put that in the
show and you guys fought me on it fought
me on it finally i was like all right
but it's because you're unguarded and
free yeah just you know going off
instinct that it it's funny yeah when it
took me a couple years to learn that
like oh don't know that's the that's
actually the thing is like that should
actually be my intention all at all
times as an actor to try and make them
laugh
to do something as outrageous and
unexpected as possible so that i can
make the people that i work with
that's certainly what we all started to
adopt and that's when the show got
really fun was when we stopped
necessarily caring about what other
people might think we should be doing
with the show and just trying to make
each other laugh quick shout out to
malcolm barrett yeah his first episode
yeah plays tyrell who was my buddy from
the luis guzman uh short-lived sitcom
that i think only three episodes aired
was the name of that show louis louie
yeah louie will gluck show yeah
originally and chris miller and phil
lord were writers on that uh we're like
staff writers oh
yeah i was like these guys are funny man
i remember i came to the recording one
of those episodes the first time i'd
ever seen a television show recorded
live
and and pt pt anderson was there thomas
anderson was outside and i smoked a
cigarette near him
yeah because he likes high art and we
were making yeah i have something
kind of the highest art form a related
experience when i was doing that 80s
show uh i got to share a cigarette with
booger
from revenge of the nerds like which is
kind of on the same on par with having a
cigarette with paul thomas anderson
yeah yeah well i again i just want to be
clear i was near him while he was
smoking and i too was right right here
so we were sharing it it was almost like
it's most tragic
was he [ __ ] 10 years old what
happened yeah rob was 10 years old
in that imagination of the scenario
[Music]
so season one episode one
i mean the show is so different without
danny yeah yeah it's just it's so
different without him it's like a
completely well certainly in this
episode for better or for worse we are
much closer to resembling actual human
beings then what we then what we quickly
become in season three or four you mean
in terms of our behavior yes in terms of
the character's behavior like we're
presenting people
who might actually exist and even though
that they are the most terrible person
on earth they were still presenting them
as being somewhat real yeah they were
much more grounded in
like the actual reality of the world as
opposed to what it became which is kind
of its own reality well it's a real bar
and they wanted to do better business
and they you know hire this guy and then
it becomes a gay bar and they're
uncomfortable with that or they're
comfortable with that based on
the profits
you're uncomfortable with it even though
you come out as gay later yes i'm
clearly the mo my character is clearly
the most homophobic in the story which
we then
uh retroactively
capitalize capitalized on seven seasons
later when we realized oh wow but if we
did we did take a look through the
behavior of the of the character over
multiple seasons and thought oh this is
pretty demonstrative of something yeah
and then we we
lean into that yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
it's all right man we're getting our sea
legs you know what i mean that's all
right yeah we got to get our sea legs
here yeah we'll we should take some
calls
let's take some calls
megan uh yeah let's take the first
caller megan who's on the line who we
got
hello
uh yeah i saw your uh first episode yeah
what'd you think
uh it was pretty boring and it mostly
sucked
uh
yeah that sounds about right yeah that
sounds good um
and i loved it and then i watched all
the 14 seasons i wonder if is there
anybody
at one point
uh that was not a gospel by the way that
was that was glenn
that was
[Laughter]
glenn one point you guys looked over and
charlie you said like how could anybody
watch this episode and be like okay
great i'm in
all right watch the next 14 years of
this show because there are truly some
repugnance
and nobody is tougher on the show than
us though i think yeah like i think i
think for
i don't know i can't i have a hard time
watching that first season it's not even
because i necessarily think it's bad i
think i just don't know
and and my sensibilities have changed so
much since we did that i just i look at
everything and i go oh god i would never
do that now as an actor as a writer or
any any any of it i would never do any
of that now
uh so so it's hard for me to stand by it
knowing that i would never yeah i would
never do that now and yet somehow people
keep watching it and i don't know why
i truly don't understand well are there
people out there do you come across like
fans who talk about like season one as
being one of their favorite seasons i
don't know i don't know no i don't think
so i know i feel like people are like oh
you're finding it
there's
there's some great stuff in season one
some great moments some great ideas
about
what the show is going to be wasn't this
yes this was the season where we had
anheuser-busch they heard that we were
making a show about a bar yeah
yes and they and they were like great
we're going to be the official beer of
that
we're aliens so we shot the whole first
season with all this signage everywhere
with anheuser-busch bloodline bud light
signs everywhere and then we aired the
first episode and the next day fx got a
call and they're like we're fully out
we're fully out and fx because we
already shot the entire season with all
of the signage and anheuser-busch was
like
i'm sorry please we're out please blur
it or we'll destroy you yeah we're out
and then our our position was [ __ ] you
you guys had the scripts you read the
script yeah then you should be fully in
and then fx was like no [ __ ] you
but if we have a relationship with them
like big fox like news corp had a big
relationship with them for the super
bowl and
and nfl football and so we had to go in
and digitally
change them all to gobbledygook yeah it
was just just like yeah beer is generic
weird though now to watch the show 15
years later and be like
budweiser gets it
they were right yeah they were right
they were right to get their asses out
of there they're like when did when did
coors come on board because then the
course doesn't care great
coors came on board board years later
once once audiences started to pick up
on what we were yeah so they were like a
better business plan yeah it is yeah
yeah let's wait until we know that are
people enjoying this yeah great we'll
advertise yeah and i i think our
position was like no you guys don't
understand this is satire and then they
were like i don't think you guys know
what satire is
and we were like yeah maybe not we are
too dumb we'll show you
then 15 years later we did mr anderson
can you tell us what satire is what is
it
what even is it get the [ __ ] out of here
heck i hear ya
so what else about this first episode
that you guys remember i remember i was
extremely sick shooting all those philly
scenes that year well you were always in
a state of sick in terms of like
starving yourself eating i don't think i
was doing that was that season
that's season two because we didn't do a
whole lot oh yeah yeah that's right
you haven't lost your mind yet
when we were all in the same trailer and
by trailer i mean closet one room yes
one room one teeny tiny little room and
uh yeah we were all stuffed in there
that was outrageous that was out and
outrageous there's things that we didn't
know we could ask for like um an office
to write the show yeah we didn't have an
office we didn't have an office we're
riding out of the house
we didn't have we didn't have trailers
we didn't have proper like yet dressing
rooms or trailers anywhere to go just a
room we shared i didn't own a computer
until the second season so we would
write on your computer i would write my
[ __ ] out on a yellow legal pack you
wrote a version of uh charlie wants an
abortion on a yellow legal pad i did
didn't you i did at the astro diner i
still have that legal pad do you i
should turn it into an nft you know oh
my god i have i actually have
fungible i actually have a whole
notebook of all of our original notes
and some shorthand
episodes written and yeah all kinds of
[ __ ] did we have an episode that we
ended up scrapping yeah i remember it
was one of the first episodes that i was
writing and it was an episode about
sweet d dating a middle eastern guy and
us being convinced that he was a
terrorist
right just a typical you know sunny
you know profiling episode yeah i don't
remember why we didn't why we ended up
maybe just wasn't good it probably just
wasn't good enough i didn't know what
the [ __ ] i was doing i'd never written
anything in my [ __ ] life it made no
sense for me to be writing his
television show i still don't know why
i'm allowed maybe that's why they didn't
give us offices yeah
these guys don't know what they're doing
they're not going to get in office i
mean i i definitely did not know what i
was doing at all it's crazy do you feel
confident about writing an episode this
year yeah yeah i do
i have a little bit of a better idea of
how to do it but uh
still not totally sure how about when we
all got to know each other because
people ask me this from time to time
they're like when did you guys get to
know each other and i no longer know i
do i do
i remember meeting you rob on a on a
flight and we're both being flown out to
test for a pilot mm-hmm
glenn i have no idea when i met you
i don't know you're everlasting
yeah i do remember the talk everlasting
everlasting audition was the first time
i met you
i was i thought that's
we were all there at the same time with
chris palace every guy that was living
in new york city i remember i walked
back to nyu or somewhere with chris
palaha after that audition yeah wait
then i walked with you because i
remember walking like to like subway
with blah yeah with pla and maybe you
you don't remember me no i can't
remember you but like that's such a
vague you know that's not a big palaha
was taller and much more striking and
then way true and then when but when did
we hang again not till we were well so
so you and i both auditioned for that
80s show
and yeah we came out to la and we tested
and what happened was we both tested for
it i was testing though for one
character and you were testing for like
my best friend yes that's correct and
then you
this is actually funny because i
remember you were like i gotta get you
you were like going back to your hotel
or something you were like i gotta get
back to my hotel and i guess i'm gonna
call a cab and i was like oh i'll drive
you and you and you were like you have a
car and i was like yeah they gave me
they gave me a rental car like they did
you know you were like surprised that
they they were like oh okay you gave you
the best friend character in the rental
car yeah exactly right i remember we
were driving away from the fox lot which
is so crazy this is
driving down pico
i get a call from my agent stephanie
ritz at the time endeavor and you were
also with endeavour stephanie calls me
she's like you got it you got the part
and i was like oh my god that's
incredibly [ __ ] i just booked the lead
in a half hour comedy that's amazing
and i was like you know what uh actually
charlie's right next to me you got any
news for him
and she was like there was like a little
pause and then she was like
yeah put charlie on
and then i just heard and i handed you
the phone and i heard you like uh-huh
uh-huh yeah
uh-huh yeah no that's that's cool
i didn't [ __ ] care yeah yeah you had
tested for like 16 pilots yeah by then i
was like this is what you do you you go
you read they think you're weird and
then and then you lose and then you lose
okay that's how it does rob i have a
distinct memory of you and i
so i used to record those ifc
oh god things and yeah coming up on ifc
it's stereo agentos whatever so being at
a place called buzzies on melrose where
i did all the things and you met me we
had coffee across the street from
buzzies and we had a conversation about
like we should just make our own [ __ ]
thing because we're sitting around
waiting for
but was that after we had
been hanging out at your apartment with
you and jimmy simpson and you guys
showed us all those
really super weird in-camera edited
movies that you guys made in new york
city you
and jimmy simpson and nate mooney and
david hornsby and
logan marshall green yeah made all these
super weird really [ __ ] funny
short movies and i remember i remember
sitting there watching those with you
rob and both of us were like oh my god
this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] funny you know
that it's like
it was the 2000 equivalent of
tick tocks or like uh right you know
like youtube videos like there was no
youtube so we just it was just for you
guys right just to show your friends
yeah yeah just but jimmy did put a
couple up on youtube and i stand by them
i think they're super fun
later yeah i think so uh but so that
conversation i don't remember where in
the timeline it happened but it was very
early yeah before we were actually doing
the show yes before we were doing the
show and i was like writing screenplays
and like trying to get i remember that i
remember distinctly going over to
charlie and jimmy's apartment with a
bunch of actor friends of ours to do a
reading like well-known i'm sure like i
mean i know it was like a bunch of
well-known people yeah pacino
yeah pacino was there yeah
and de niro was there and then you knew
paul thomas anderson
yeah he was there
i had booked
no but but i remember like sitting
around and doing it like a quote-unquote
table read like just a round table read
with of uh billie jean yeah billie jean
yeah yeah did lin did lynn collins play
billy g yes yes that's right yeah billie
jean is something i wrote with with
bacchus
yeah and i remember it being pretty
funny and yeah i was like oh it was good
we can do this but then it's so hard to
get anything through to the machine so
you'd send it to somebody and they'd be
like oh i'll rate it and then three
weeks later they'd just forget about it
and that'd be the end of it and so then
you you know watching charlie's home
movies i was just doing like what the
[ __ ] why are we waiting for somebody
else let's just make it ourselves yeah
also
the british office the the like yes the
run and gun look of that the cheap the
cheap look of it yeah to be like oh
right okay and curb
and curb yeah and the invention of that
panasonic dvx-100a
like that camera
looked
like those shows yes it was the first
time that you could have like a
consumer-grade camera that didn't look
like a videotape like vhs it looked like
closer to what we understood as film and
so we thought oh wow we can fake this a
little bit better yeah so it was like
the difference between like those home
movies doing with jimmy
he was doing those we're shooting those
on like a little tiny sony digital thing
that he'd gotten the money from that amy
heckerling movie loser he had a big part
in that and he put like all his money
into like
renting an apartment
that like
the landlord was a crackhead it was
above a grace papaya it smelled like hot
dogs the whole time
and and
and this and this video camera but then
the panasonic you shot something and
you're like but this looks
yeah i mean like a tv show like a tv
show right right this looks professional
yes of course you look at it now and it
looks like absolute trash the shows
always look terrible at the time it
really felt like wow we're we can make
something look good and that look
spilled over into
the pilot that was shot with fx yeah and
i remember us insisting we were like we
came in you know guns blazing we were
like this is how we want to shoot the
show and every director everybody we
talked to like that's [ __ ] great you
can't shoot it that way that makes no
sense we're like well we can because we
just did we did with nothing with no
resources just no lights no marks no
lights no marks just you know and we
even resisted in that whole first season
we did not allow our our director of
photography to put marks down i i think
most people know what that is at this
point probably but it's a little piece
of tape you put on the ground
where the actor is supposed to stand
because the light is perfect for them
yeah the lights right you got to be in
focus block the other actor in the shot
right you're not going to catch the
other camera if you've got two cameras
rolling or whatever but i remember the
main thing people took exception to is
that we wanted to shoot three cameras at
all times we had one person
shooting wide shooting a wide master
and then if it was a two-person scene we
had somebody shooting you know let's say
it was a scene between me and rob maybe
one camera on rob one camera on me and
one camera shooting the master even at
the time we were making our thing and
then we would we would shoot right and
then we would go and we'd look at it cut
together and we'd be like something's
weird they're just looking at each other
but it looks like one's looking in one
direction one's looking in the other but
we had to figure out in real time oh we
didn't know the lines yeah
yeah like we just didn't know we just
started doing it and now and i don't
remember that yeah i thought i don't
remember that in fact yeah if you look
at the first one there's some weird
eyeline things that don't make any sense
we didn't know why because we had no
[ __ ] idea what we were doing yeah
yeah also we were not shooting it to
sell it i don't know where your head was
at but i i know for me i was like oh i
just want to shoot a funny home movie
like what charlie and those guys did in
new york and just just to show people to
make my friends laugh and in my mind it
was like we're shooting like this little
short film thing and then i remember we
looked at it we were like it's weird it
feels like a tv show yep because that
was not the original intention no no it
was to see something all the way
concerned we were with white balancing
oh my
we got a white god
we gotta white balance these cameras man
this is everything otherwise two shots
don't look the same oh my god that's
right well at least we had the presence
of mind at least we knew how to do that
yeah we didn't know we made it sound
like we didn't know anything but we like
we knew something oh just the bare
minimum we had a boom
we knew enough to have a boom no well we
didn't have a real we had a directional
mic that we turned into a boom boom
we had a directional mic hanging from a
broomstick yeah it was a broom
we had a broom i said what did you hear
[Music]
[Applause]
oh what'd you guys have for breakfast
[Music]
this is what they they don't want to
hear about the show they just want to
hear this kind of [ __ ]
the rock would say what he had for
breakfast
i had nothing you didn't eat anything
for breakfast no
what's the first what are you interested
in you're wondering why you're you're
having stomach problems what time did
you eat for the first time today i for
the first time today when we had lunch
charlie did you have coffee i had a ton
of coffee yeah yeah but coffee doesn't
really bother my stomach cheese no she's
just cheese you made this clear you
can't drink rob can't drink i don't
drink coffee i just sometimes i'll have
breakfast but today i didn't
i was running out the door okay you know
what um
what kind of woody bench
[Laughter]
my badge has gone down significantly
since covered get up i i gotta put up
there but i'd be yeah i have no idea yes
no idea what i can bench no clue three
chairs i think it's okay for a 44 year
old man not to know what he can bench i
think are you 45 i'm 45 yeah i wasn't
gonna say anything um
cut that yeah
got that cut back cut that 45.
so yeah
[Laughter]
how old were we when we started doing
this chat 27 years old i know i was 27
when we shot the original home movie and
then 28 when we shot the fx pilot yeah
right so we like to think that we were
like super young but we really weren't
like the beatles had broken up by the
time they were 26. most people most
artists have done they're better than
ourselves at the beatles we're gonna
have a hard time here no we're gonna
have a hard day's night
yeah you guys most artists i would say
have probably done their best work by
the time we started this show
and they were like well past it
we were just warming up and then that
feels like a lifetime ago you never want
to peek too soon because it was
yeah because it was well we can't
remember any any of it but that's the
pinot grigio and the bourbon for me
pinot grigio and bourbon well i don't
mix them together but there was a period
of my life a good eight years why i
drank pinot grigio and i don't drink
that anymore i just drink bourbon now do
you you sweat you burp switch to bourbon
yeah drink burn i don't know you to be a
bourbon i wasn't a bourbon drinker until
um the until we all locked down for the
global pandemic okay we don't have to go
into it on the podcast but i want to
hear about the bourbons that you're into
are you super into it are you drinking
i'm super into it no you are yeah yeah
no i've got a couple recommendations
okay okay maybe they'll be sponsors hey
yeah
you know what i really have been into is
rye whiskey i'll drink i'll drink some
rye i really like a i don't know
something about rice i don't like it
when my liquors are too sweet so like a
lot of tequilas are too agave forward if
you will
uh i want a dry experience
i would submit that some people do want
to hear this charlotte no no no i'm sure
they do
i'm just trying to talk about something
yeah yeah yeah again it's 73 degrees out
los angeles today the avaya the
available wi-fi network is fox and
friends uh
just talking about your phone
just talking about your phone looking at
your phone
well guys this has been fun i like
talking about whiskey
oh yeah i thought that was cool you ever
had a japanese whiskey yeah yeah yeah
yeah
they're making some good ones these days
yeah i went to japan it was awesome
oh okay yeah cool you still have cats
yeah one i got one
one of those cats is still alive yeah
bean's still alive 19 years old
that's insane she's old as [ __ ] yeah
yeah wow i remember you getting those
cats
yeah i i'm surprised she hasn't had a
heart attack from the dogs at this point
honestly that's tough thing like
18 years into a cat like to bring in two
dogs yeah bring bringing a couple dogs
and
yeah they just want to gobble her up
cat's like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
man what are you doing yeah she it's
really funny every time she takes a [ __ ]
she's
[Music]
you like want to get that jet
you might want to get that oh there's no
getting it checked at this point it's
like you're 19. everything's gonna
[ __ ] hurt but it it like something
every time she takes a [ __ ] she's like
i'm concerned about your cat man man no
have you talked about i'm taking it in
to get checked have you talked to a vet
about this i mean
is she in pain
i don't know what she's doing
she might be in ecstasy listen guys she
might be she's got that got that cut
that got that cut
she might be an ecstasy guy she might be
an ecstasy so you're saying you can't
tell the difference whether a female is
in pain or an ecstasy aren't they the
same thing cut that guy
[Music]
you